nettle euro step  whistle foul counted paul  nedo and one if i'm gonna give credit to  the raptors bench then you gotta give  credit to the sixes bench  jumping up and down almost running the  half court  supporting young nettle pick and roll  action gets into the thick  of the raptors defense big time finish  with the left hand going to the line  with a chance to put his team up too  boy that was an impressive finish and  the sixers lead by a bucket  [Applause]  johnson faked the handoff and ties it at  121.  a slick move and take by stanley johnson  well these benches look like they're on  family feud oh yeah it's going back and  forth  it's a battle on two fronts  nettle wide open three  raptors with the rebound and adrian  griffin says  i've been waiting a long time to draw  one up  with 18 seconds to play  the raptors with a 13-5 run stanley  johnson  fake the dribble handoff  and with that the bench  really happy with the finish after this